we don't have a deep understanding of
the builders response but it's
interesting that if you put together
what we know from this orders of brain
function and the normal physiology we
begin to understand an outline what the
beholders response is and this is so
important because in 1906 when Freud was
active and claimed Koko's Kanchi Levy's
artists were active there was a major
person at the Vienna School of Art
History called a Louis regal and he said
the problem with art history is it's
going to go down the tubes because it's
too anecdotal it's too descriptive it
doesn't have enough of a science base
it's got to become more scientific and
the science it should relate itself to
is psychology and the key problem that
it should address right off is the
beholder share you have a painting that
painting is not complete until the
viewer responds to it it's obvious once
you say it you know this is why it was
painted in the first place but he
pointed out this has become more
explicit in the history of art if you
look at Renaissance art particularly
early Renaissance art it's very inner
directed and he points to a painting in
Florence
of the Trinity in Santa Maria Novella
painted by masaccio which has one of the
early paintings to show you a wonderful
sense of perspective you see Christ on
the cross you see Mary and Joseph
they're turning toward him God is above
he looks down the two donors at the side
they look in they're all looking at
Christ it's a very inner directed
picture and it doesn't really recruit
the involvement of the beholder
dramatically but as odd involved
particularly when you move to Dutch art
which Frida was very impressed with you
see that there's a conscious attempt on
the part of the painter to paint people
who look at you who enter
act with you and that made him aware of
the fact of how important the beholder
was and to try to understand how does
the builders response works he had two
very gifted students Ernst Chris and
Ernst Gombrich and they began to put
this on a really rigorous basis Ernst
Chris said great works are great because
they ambiguous they allow for
alternative readings so you and I look
at that masaccio painting we would have
somewhat different responses to it which
means that the beholder share varies for
each of us because we see somewhat
different things in the painting now
what does that mean you said if that
means that beholder share varies that
means you and I must be creating
different images in our brain about that
particular portrait so even though you
and I looking at the same object in the
world we're creating slightly different
visual impressions in our mind emotional
impressions in our mind by looking at
this and they began to document that
first he and then Gombrich showed you
how you can trick the mind into
alternate interpretations with illusions
of various kinds and they began to
realize that when you look at the
painting you undergoing a creative
experience that is at least an outline
similar to the painter the painter --ax
exercises a dramatic amount of
creativity in doing a portrait but you
yourself generate a fair amount of
creativity in reconstructing it in your
head and reconstructing it in a way that
it's unique for you and slightly
different for me this was a remarkable
insight and is really given rise to sort
of the current understanding of what
goes on in our head the painting the
Mona Lisa by Laura da Vinci is generally
considered one of the great masterpieces
of Western art and the reason it's so
great is for the same reason we talked
about before it has a great deal of
ambiguity
and ambiguities what brings out
differences of interpretation makes
contributes to work being great and with
power one of the very specific points of
ambiguity is the nature of a facial
expression is she smiling or is she not
and there's been endless discussions
about this and we want to stand why does
that ambiguity arise and there are two
major interpretations one is it's the
form of painting that Leonardo use in
which he purposely paints over the edges
of the mouth a technique called stomata
or smoke so it's a little bit hazy and
not clearly outlined then that gives
rise to the ambiguity and Marge
Livingston has made the point it's how
you focus on it if you focus on it with
central vision which sees detailed you
don't see the smile if you focus on
peripheral vision which sees the broad
outlines you do better seeing the smile